so first of all two reports out today
show there's been a huge expansion in
renewable energy capacity across the
world but there's also warning that it's
not enough to reach global net zero
targets by the middle of the century and
now first of all i just want to point
out what the iea have said about this
they say that
this year's record renewable electricity
editions are another sign that a new
global energy economy is emerging would
you agree it's really good news isn't it
yeah it is good news i mean it's uh the
extension of a trend which we've been
seeing for actually for quite a long
time um and especially after uh in the
last couple of years it's been very
difficult to get financing for new
uh fossil fuel projects which
is a climatically very positive step so
you know this is part of a trajectory
which we've been mapping
the question is is the rate of change
sufficiently fast um and i think
most views would be that no it isn't but
the
there are reasons to be optimistic that
uh you know the rate of change will it
will increase uh to the appropriate
levels well yes and we'll come back to
that but mika what do you make of this
do you think it shows that the world is
taking climate change seriously
i think those answers are never binary
and we always have to ask how can we do
more and faster and how can we
accelerate the rate of the transition
while waking it while making it
equitable and sustainable
uh worth it for investors worth it for
private companies worth it for
individuals so we can all benefit from
those changes now the point here is that
this is a virtuous circle potentially
between policy making and between um the
private sector policy making has uh sent
positive signals as the ia notes in its
report that have facilitated this
transition
continuing those um
signals is what enables faster
deployment of renewables
but also we need to remember the
complete the competing and the
completing side of this which is fossil
fuels
the more we legislate and regulate
fossil fuel consumption exploration and
so on
the more that we are more uh the more
that we can advance renewables and that
is a really important thing to to to do
those things to intend them now the
policy measures that will advance
renewable energy and drive down the cost
of those will enable us to do more
to have even more ambitious policy
measures in place
bringing um forward for example
india's uh uh ndc target which is
currently a net zero by 2070 and
currently facilitated by the current
prices of renewables bring those down
with faster deployment globally and
we'll be able to bring that um even
faster well yes another do you agree
with that because as you were hinting
the the ia is saying at the moment the
rate of increase is not fast enough to
hit those net zero targets so
how much is this down to governments do
you think and how much will it be down
to market forces
well market forces are working very
conveniently for a lot of renewables
so
in large parts of the world practically
everywhere
renewables are cost competitive or
undercutting the price of new uh fossil
fuels which is why we're seeing the
balance of
new capacity that you described earlier
for the purposes of governments though
what we're seeing is that whilst a lot
of progress is being made in a lot of
places there is still really strong
financial pipeline for
new fossil fuel investments
through export credit agencies through
the belt and road initiative in china so
you know there's there's there's there
are a number of different stories here
there's the you know open
market liberal um world and then you
know there's the larger part of the
world frankly in which this isn't uh the
case so you know if you look along the
belton road you'll see
huge uh uh the pipeline of uh coal power
plants the uh transmission of fossil
fuels is still in a relatively healthy
place and that is just not at all
consistent with a one and a half degree
or even a two and a two degree world
mikhail very briefly um there was an
agreement at cop as well among some
countries to stop in
investing in overseas fossil fuel plants
i mean that's progress as well isn't it
but we need to remember that not invest
not investing in coal for example is
important but building infrastructure
that is very carbon intensive um such as
the belt and road initiative is
something that will lock us into many
years
of uh
of of carbon intensive uh usage of that
infrastructure and those things are
really important to remember so like
maverick said we really needed to um
make those policy steps now
both on the fossil fuels and on the
renewables and those work in tandem the
sooner that fossil fuels uh will be
um
not uh competitive and some of them
already aren't
with renewable energy the easier will be
to phase those out